now we are awaiting a ruling on the fate
of title 42 with reports it could come
as early as today now that the trump-era
border restrictions are set to expire on
monday
illegal migrant encounters which have
already shattered records month after
month are now exploding with some areas
seeing 1800 apprehensions in just 24
hours and with title 42 expected to end
border counties are now bracing for
disaster el paso is preparing to declare
a state of emergency
as the governor of texas warns 6 million
migrants could come in each year
that's roughly equal to the population
of houston
every 12 months
and with all this hanging in the balance
you may be wondering what our borders
are is up to today
well vice president kamala harris is
talking about clean school buses
kaylee as always the vice president is
m.i.a on this border crisis but today
she is expected to announce certain
regulations and expectations surrounding
low emissions school buses what apt
timing and what great priorities
wouldn't you say
right what a priority i'm still not
listening to the pollsters emily
remember we've talked about that that
joe biden's pollsters came into him and
said hey i know it may feel like your
administration's going great but there's
this thing on the horizon it's called
immigration and a border on fire maybe
you want to pay attention to it well he
didn't and neither has kamala harris
because fox news digital did some really
good reporting on this here's what they
found in june she visits the border for
a photo op okay
in august the la times tracked just two
limited press events there have been no
such press events since last june
and since june the other recorded
activity we have from her on the border
is january she went to honduras april
she had a phone call may she had a
meeting good job kamala harris a meeting
a phone call a photo op at the border a
photo up in honduras and now you have
title 42 which is about to expire
meaning two million more illegal
migrants would have crossed the southern
border this administration the only
conclusion you're left with emily is
that they are intentionally trying to
make this worse because why
why would you not lift the mass mandate
on airlines until a judge forces you to
u.s citizens but yet you will willingly
lift covet restrictions for illegal
migrants before then it makes no sense
that's right and michelle as kaylee
outlined this the dearth of
communications that really belies the
lack of support there for all of those
border states and frankly all the rest
of the 24 states that have joined this
lawsuit lawsuit trying to keep title 42
in place in fact governor abbott of
texas said that the last time he spoke
to the president president biden on any
subject was february of
2021 what does this tell you michelle it
tells me that they really just don't
care i mean i can't imagine that this is
a priority for them and it's it's
devastating to those border states but
it's really devastating to the country
look all we want
is an orderly
immigration system and by ripping off
this title 42 band-aid you're still
leaving the patient bleeding you're
leaving the patient needing really some
surgery but we hear again and again from
nancy pelosi and others we need
comprehensive immigration reform i've
been hearing that i think since i was
alive since i've been alive and that is
going to take so long to accomplish and
there's going to be so much disagreement
in all the details that is not going to
resolve this issue we need to look
specifically at the border first and
then take care of the rest of the
immigration reform this is a major
problem we're having fentanyl get
through we're having the cartels control
so much of what's going on over there
that it
it really does look like this
administration just doesn't care or sees
an advantage here and that's hard for
most americans to take that's right and
kennedy in terms of the arguments the
acknowledgments and the actual lawsuit
over title 42 the administration has
never acknowledged all of the arguments
on behalf of the states where they say
look our entire systems education law
enforcement processing will absolutely
crush not only our local populations
they say but also the migrants who
deserve as well to be processed in an
orderly fashion to michelle's point
about the immigration reform needed and
instead the government has simply said
the cdc is the one department with the
authority and therefore that's why this
should be lifted there's absolutely no
concept no appreciation of all of those
millions of americans and all of those
migrant lives who will be affected
negatively if this title should be
lifted kennedy uh covet doesn't infect
people who might one day become democrat
voters and everyone knows that science
knows that and we have to acknowledge
that now
so they've had a year they saw what
happened last year with these record
numbers of people coming over the border
and now with title 42 going away
whatever great marketing the cartels
have last year it's even better this
year because they're like they're not
even going to send you back to mexico
when you're seeking asylum you you are
in
and they've had a year to have a
comprehensive approach even if the
comprehension isn't in legislation uh
they they could have had more judges
more processing facilities more insights
i know kamala harris wears pantsuits i
know pantsuits have sleeves she should
be rolling them up and doing the really
hard work that is required to solve this
because americans have been suffering
people trying to get into the country
have been suffering and dying so
she if she is the tsarina she must rule
on this one
and jimmy this this has such a an
exponential effect right so one day with
an open spigot has a ripple effect and
an impact that is is far greater than
the actual numeric equivalent if that
makes any sense basically it's really
hard to stuff this genie back in the
bottle right every day that goes by the
border crisis
is very emblematic of why joe biden and
kamala harris are the only people
pulling behind johnny depp and amber
hurst
i mean
understand this from like a 20 000 foot
view it's a now problem it's going on
right now and right now they're not
offering a now solution like if your
house is on fire it's a now problem you
need a truck with water now instead
kamala's response was what we'll do a
study on the root causes of immigration
can you imagine calling the fire
department you're like the house is on
fire they're like you're in luck we're
gonna do a study on the root causes of
house fires you're gonna love it these
are not serious people and i know i'm
making light of it because that's how i
cope with such awful things because the
suffering that's been created in this
country by their indifference to the
border because they see the border as a
political issue and they depicted border
security as racist under trump but the
drugs coming across the border affect
every race it's not exclusive to like
white people and that's the part that
drives me crazy the border is the front
door of our house it's wide open we
don't know who's coming in or out of the
house this is not a principle of black
or white it's a principle of right or
wrong and that's what disgusts me but
really quick the kamala thing with the
school buses i know i'm dressed like a
guy who's not allowed within 500 feet of
a school but let me just say okay if you
really want to do something with
vehicles to help the environment make
the u-hauls electric that are fleeing
democrats states and will solve
everything bravo i do have to say when
you first said house fire i thought you
said something else but that's on fire
too
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainslie earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis